once against the source of controversy
this time over new text messages
obtained by the daily mail
showing hunter repeatedly using the
n-word while texting with his white
lawyer the messages are from late 2018
in early 2019 and we've reached out to
hunter biden's attorney for comment
but have yet to hear back so jesse one
of my favorite parts about this
and there are many of them is that he
complained about no one defending him
but
everyone's been defending him recently
well well well i don't know i was all
fired up about this segment and now
you know guys using racial slurs like am
i going to get giddy about this
it's like very troubling i guess the
media won't report it and here's really
why
because to acknowledge what's happening
on the laptop
acknowledges the other stuff on the
laptop
holding 10 for the big guy all the shady
foreign deals from the biden crime
family
if you say yeah he said the n word on
the laptop then the media has to report
all the other stuff and they just
installed this guy
the laptop from hell can bring down this
presidency they can't touch this thing
so you have the son of a sitting
president just casually dropping n-bombs
and the u.s media won't touch it i mean
they wanted to put
don junior's head on a stake because he
retweeted a meme
and this guy gets away with everything
well greg there's a lot in here that we
can only talk about on the gg show
but hunter did say i'm sorry for sexting
you accidentally that was meant for
another friend named georgia
after he realized he was texting the
wrong person
all these explicit messages you know
the big i don't like looking at people's
private texts because i always imagine
it's me
that's that's the text but the fact is
this is on a laptop that he let out
loose into the world and but the point
to me is that this
is the guy that the media big tech
and the democrats colluded to protect
when you go through all this stuff you
know this guy is a really slimy dude but
it's like
this is the one guy that they chose out
of the whole world to protect
because they wanted his dad to win and
they hated trump so much
um i will i'll defend him on this point
he could be a hero
for all the screw-ups if the media
continues to excuse him for
all the bad things he does every bad guy
can now point to that and go you can't
cancel me look at this journey that's
what he did
like if you're going to come after me
you never said a word about it i mean
chris harrison's got to be like you got
you got to be kidding me yeah yeah right
i'm gone and this guy's still working
for the white house ellie kemper
apologized for
going to a debutante ball 20 years ago
in which it was after that it had been d
uh whatever it was de-racing de-racing
and this guy this guy can do this stuff
with that and they just
you're right it's just like he can do
whatever he wants because it makes
the media steps to the plate and does
their job they have to admit they didn't
do their job they were corrupted
they colluded and they were corrupted
dana it's like we're at the point of no
return with how bad this is going to get
well greg used to talk about the pig
pass yes right so this is like
the presidential pig pass like he gets
the pass
but i do think that comparisons to
previous administration
is fair imagine if this had been um
somebody
in the trump family like we there would
be nothing else to talk to oh my god
for years years and years geraldo they
say that you're only as happy as your
unhappiest child
i mean i feel so sorry for his parents
it is so humiliating so embarrassing
and that it's the president of the
united states he wanted that job his
whole life
he got that job and here's his schmucky
son you know doing these things that are
so
down and dirty so distasteful i i really
i
i lament for them that uh this guy is
their last name
he's still having fun though he is he is
an artist now hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else